This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many years ago, the corporation for public broadcasting was on the chopping block. President Richard Nixon wanted to radically slash its proposed budget. Supporters of CPP, as it's known, took that case to a congressional hearing. They have committed against hearings on S1242. They argued that $20 million was a small amount of pay for the many educational and entertainment television programs that the public broadcaster would generate. In hour after hour of testimony, advocates argued that funding public broadcasting was
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。很多年前，公共广播公司曾面临生死存亡的关头。理查德·尼克松总统希望大幅削减其提议的预算。正如大家所知，公共广播公司的支持者们将这一诉讼带到了一场国会听证会上。他们反对就S1242法案举行听证会。他们辩称，对于公共广播公司将制作的大量教育和娱乐电视节目而言，2000万美元只是一笔很小的开支。在接下来的数小时作证中，倡导者们辩称，资助公共广播
good for America and good for America's children. A number of scientific studies pointed to the fact that America may be literally important to government hearings and other public activities. The head of the Congressional Committee, Senator John Pastore of Rhode Island, had a reputation for being tough-minded and impatient. All right, now when you answer my question, have you not done this? After a deluge of data and declarations had been presented to his committee, a famous children's television host took the stage. His name was Fred Rogers.
对美国有益，对美国儿童也有益。许多科学研究指出，美国可能从字面上对政府听证会和其他公共活动至关重要。国会委员会负责人、来自罗德岛州的参议员约翰·帕斯托雷以坚毅和急躁著称。好了，现在当您回答我的问题时，您没有这样做过吗？在向他的委员会提交了大量数据和声明之后，一位著名的儿童电视节目主持人登上了舞台。他的名字叫弗雷德·罗杰斯。
All right, Rogers, you got the floor. He talked about what his program meant to America's children. I end the program by saying, you've made this day a special day by just you're being you. The Children's Television host asked the senator if he could recite the words to a song from his program. It was about self-esteem, self-control, and emotional regulation. I can stop when I want to, can stop when I wish,
好了，罗杰斯，现在请发言。他谈到了他的节目对美国儿童意味着什么。我在节目结束时说，只要做你自己，你就让这一天变得特别。这位儿童电视节目主持人问参议员，他是否能背诵他节目中一首歌的词。这首歌关于自尊、自我控制和情绪调节。我想停下来的时候就能停下来，想停就能停，
can stop, stop, stop, time, and what a good feeling to feel like this, and know that the feeling is really mine, know that there's something deep inside that helps us become what we can. I think it's wonderful. I think it's wonderful. Looks like you just earned the 20 million dollars. Thank you. Thank you.
能停、停、停，暂停，这种感觉多好啊，而且知道这种感觉真正属于我，知道内心深处有些东西能帮助我们成为我们可能成为的人。我觉得这太棒了。我觉得这太棒了。看来你刚刚赢得了2000万美元。谢谢。谢谢。
All of us in every walk of life, at every stage of life, need buy-in from others. Sometimes, you need legislators to fund your project. Other times, you might need your co-workers to sign on to a new initiative, or you might need to convince your teacher to change your grade on an assignment. This week on Hidden Brain, the common mistake we make that undermines the effectiveness of our pleas and how to make better arguments that stick. Think about a time when you try to change someone's mind. Maybe you were convincing your boss to give you a promotion, or explaining to a friend why she should vote for a particular politician.
我们所有人，在生活的各个阶段，在人生的每个转折点，都需要获得他人的认同。有时，你需要立法者来资助你的项目。其他时候，你可能需要同事支持一项新倡议，或者你需要说服老师修改你在某项作业中的评分。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨我们常犯的一个错误——它削弱了我们陈述的有效性，以及如何提出更有说服力的论点。回想一下你试图改变某人想法的时候。也许你正在说服老板给你升职，或者向朋友解释她为什么应该投票给某个特定的政治家。
Did you give much thought to the way you were crafting your argument? Did you think about the phrases you would use? The evidence you would present? At London Business School, Nero Sivanathan studies the psychology of the arguments we make. Nero Sivanathan, welcome to Hidden Brain. How you chunk of wonderful to be here. Nero, I understand that when you were a kid, you were an avid video gamer. What kind of games were you fascinated by? I think I played anything and everything I could get my hands on.
你是否仔细考虑过你构建论点的方式？你有没有想过你要使用的词句？你要提出的证据？在伦敦商学院，尼罗·西瓦纳坦研究我们所提出的论点的心理学。尼罗·西瓦纳坦，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。尼罗，我听说你小时候是个狂热的电子游戏玩家。你对哪类游戏着迷？我想我玩过我能接触到的任何游戏。
I think it was a typical 10-year-old. I spent far too much time in front of the TV back then and not necessarily screens, but TV playing, I think I had Nintendo 16 and I was saying a genesis, I think, kind of dating myself. But yeah, those were the systems I grew up on. Like many kids who are into video games, Nero had to battle a couple of really big obstacles. His mom and his dad. I think there was always a constant battle and a wrestling of arguments with my parents for when I got to play, how often, and for the duration.
我想我当时就像一个典型的10岁孩子。那时我花在电视前的时间太多了，不一定是看屏幕，而是玩电视游戏，我想我有任天堂16，还有世嘉Genesis，这有点暴露我的年龄了。但是的，那些就是我伴其成长的主机系统。和许多热爱电子游戏的儿童一样，尼罗不得不与两个巨大的障碍作斗争。他的妈妈和爸爸。我想，为了我什么时候能玩、玩多长时间以及玩多久，我和父母之间总是免不了一场持久的争论和拉锯战。
So yes, typical battles with parents. Nero tried to come up with every possible reason. He should be allowed to play more video games. One time, he even turned an assignment in French class into an argument about the benefits of a particular video game. So in Canada, you are required to take French till grade 9, and that's across the entire education system. There are lots of things I could do well, Shankar, but learning language was not one of them,
所以是的，这是与父母之间的典型争论。尼罗试图想出各种可能的理由，证明自己应该被允许玩更多电子游戏。有一次，他甚至把法语课的作业变成了一篇论证某个特定电子游戏好处的论文。在加拿大，你必须学习法语直到9年级，整个教育系统都是如此。尚卡尔，我有很多事情可以做得很好，但学习语言绝对不在其中，
and so I did pretty well generally in school but did not do so well in French and specifically vocabulary. And so one year I think I had an assignment for my French class and I decided I would write about the benefits of playing video games. I sort of thought through this and then had the usual arguments that it would help me with eye-hand coordination, problem solving, thinking outside the box, etc. But the thesis of that essay was that it was also crucial in my ability to learn French and specifically remember words and increase my vocabulary. And not surprisingly, I didn't do so well on that essay, but this was
所以我总的来说在学校表现不错，但在法语尤其是词汇方面学得不太好。所以有一年，我想我有一份法语课的作业，我决定写一篇关于玩电子游戏好处的文章。我仔细思考过这一点，然后提出了通常的论据，即它能帮我提高手眼协调能力、解决问题的能力、跳出思维定式的能力等。但那篇论文的中心论点是，它对我的法语学习能力，尤其是记忆单词和增加词汇量也至关重要。不出所料，那篇论文我考得不太好，但这
also something that was shared with my parents. Needless to say, that didn't necessarily help me at home with my battles for playing more video games. So in other words, the argument you were making to your parents was video games not only helped me with hand-eye coordination and are a form of entertainment, but they're also going to help me master this difficult language that I'm not doing while at school. That's right. So I think the game that I was probably referring to was I think Zelda or the legend of Zelda, I forget what the exact title was where there are all sorts of foreign words. And my argument was that if I could remember these foreign words that are sort of nonsensical, certainly French words,
也是和父母分享过的事情。不用说，这在家里对我和父母争取玩更多电子游戏的战斗并没有什么实质帮助。换句话说，你当时向父母提出的论点是：电子游戏不仅能帮我锻炼手眼协调能力，是一种娱乐形式，而且还能帮我掌握这门我在学校学得不太好的困难语言？没错。所以我想我当时可能指的是《塞尔达传说》之类的游戏，我忘了确切的名字，里面有各种各样的外语词汇。我的论据是，如果我能记住这些听起来毫无意义的外语词汇，那么法语词汇
which are equally nonsensical to me would be a breeze. That, yeah, as you could imagine from your laughter, it didn't go so well. I think when I was drafting the essay, it seemed to make perfect sense, but unfortunately, that didn't land so well. It was not the last time Nero would find his arguments falling short. Much later in life after he became a professor he found himself advocating that a particular student be
对我来说同样毫无意义，自然也就轻而易举了。正如你从笑声中能想象到的那样，结果并不怎么顺利。我想我在起草论文时，觉得这完全讲得通，但不幸的是，这个论点并没有取得好效果。这并不是尼罗最后一次发现自己的论点不够有力。多年后，在他成为教授之后，他发现自己正在为争取让某位特定学生
admitted into the school's PhD program. There was one applicant that I was incredibly passionate about. I thought had great potential. They had phenomenal research experience. So I had publication already in a top tier journal, even before they started the PhD program, which back then was pretty rare. Their grades were good, but not great. And perhaps their pedigree for the university wasn't necessarily
被学校博士项目录取而四处奔走。有一位申请者让我极其充满热情。我认为他有着巨大的潜力。他们拥有非凡的研究经验。因此，甚至在他们开始博士项目之前，他就已经在顶级期刊上发表过论文，这在当时是相当罕见的。他们的成绩很好，但并非顶尖。而且也许他们在大学出身背景方面未必
kind of top shelf, but needless to say, it was respectable. Nero thought the student was a perfect fit for the program. When it came time to present him to the application committee, Nero did his best to notice strengths, namely his research experience. But Nero also tried to justify why the students' grades were not stellar. Highlighted that their undergrad was in a more difficult subject than what we typically get in an applicant pool and so forth.
算是顶尖货色，但不用说，还是相当体面的。尼罗认为这个学生非常适合这个项目。到了向申请委员会介绍他的时候，尼罗尽最大努力指出了他的长处，即他的研究经验。但尼罗同时也试图证明为什么该学生的成绩并非十分耀眼。他强调说，他们的本科专业比我们通常收到的申请者群体的专业更难，诸如此类。
That then resulted in a conversation which centered around the grades and whether this person would be a good fit and very quickly sort of deviated from the type of conversation that I had sort of forecasted or hoped for and unfortunately this candidate was not accepted into the program. This individual went on to get accepted into a wonderful institution and is now one of the most prominent academics or young academics in the field.
这随之引发了一场对话，对话的焦点落在了成绩以及这个人是否合适上，并且很快就偏离了我原本预测或希望的那种对话方向，不幸的是，这位候选人没有被该项目录取。后来，这个人被一所极好的机构录取，现在已成为该领域最杰出的学者或青年学者之一。
It's one of those cases where I wish I did a better job sponsoring and promoting that individual to the committee. You can probably remember moments like this when you tried and failed to make your case effectively. Maybe you lost an argument with your spouse over how to parent your child or you failed to persuade your boss to start a new project. Of course, failures of persuasion can also happen on a much larger scale. Nero has examined a case from the early 1980s when a new illness called AIDS was ravaging
这是一个让我感到后悔的案例，我真希望当时能更好地为该候选人向委员会进行赞誉和推广。你大概也能记起这样的时刻：你曾试图有效地阐明自己的观点却遭遇失败。也许你曾因如何教育孩子而与配偶争论失败，或者你未能说服老板启动一个新项目。当然，说服的失败也可能发生在更大的范围内。尼罗曾研究过20世纪80年代初的一个案例，当时一种名为艾滋病的崭新疾病正在席卷
communities across the United States. In 1983, the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention held a meeting on the crisis. Officials from the CDC took a stance that they thought would help slow the spread of the disease. The CDC for months had collected copy-sonments of data that allowed them to come to the conclusion that HIV was related to AIDS, and that it could also be transmitted through plasma or specifically blood. And this was an open meeting to various stakeholders.
全美国的各个社区。1983年，疾病控制与预防中心就这场危机举行了一次会议。疾控中心的官员们采取了一种他们认为有助于减缓疾病传播的立场。几个月来，疾控中心收集了大量数据，使他们得出结论：艾滋病毒与艾滋病有关，而且它也可以通过血浆或特别是血液传播。这是一次面向各利益相关方的公开会议。
And I think the core stakeholders that they cared about was I think it was the American Red Cross, the AABB, which I think was the American Association of Blood Banks, along with many other stakeholders. And their hope was to present all this data as a way to convince them that moving forward, they should screen for HIV when they take blood donations. And the hope was that once this data was presented,
我想他们关心的核心利益相关者应该是美国红十字会、美国血库协会（AABB），以及许多其他利益相关者。他们希望展示所有这些数据，以此来说服他们在未来的血液捐献中应该对艾滋病毒进行筛查。他们的希望是，一旦这些数据展示出来，
it would be very clear and there would be a set of protocols or structures that we put in place for both blood donations and obviously then the transmission of blood for those who might need a blood transfusion. Obviously here there are public health stakes because the blood transfusions are now going into other patients, for example, in hospitals and if the AIDS virus was in the blood, you could potentially infect somebody who was healthy. That's right. And so this was, you know, we've had other health epidemics since then. This back in the the 80s was, you know, we've had other health epidemics since then. This back in the 80s was, you know, was front and center room, and there was a huge push both, as you said, at the policy level, but elsewhere to try and curtail the spread.
一切就会非常清晰，并且我们会为血液捐献以及显然随后为那些可能需要输血的人提供的血液输送建立一套规程或结构。显然，这里存在公共卫生风险，因为血液输水现在正注入其他患者体内，例如医院里的患者，如果艾滋病病毒存在于血液中，你就有可能感染健康的人。没错。所以这是，你知道的，自那以后我们还经历过其他健康流行病。早在80年代的时候，你知道的，这处于焦点中心，并且正如你所说，无论是政策层面还是其他地方，都有巨大的推动力试图遏制疫情的蔓延。
And unfortunately, the meeting didn't go as planned, where lots of questions were posed through multiple avenues around the legitimacy of the data, the recommendations by CDC and so forth. And frankly, nothing came out of that meeting, and most certainly a far cry from what they were hoping for, which was a screening of HIV. Now, some estimates suggest that as a failure of that meeting, an additional 12,000 people were either infected or died from tainted blood transfusions. To the stakes were very high. The data was crystal clear.
不幸的是，会议并未按计划进行，通过多种途径提出了许多关于数据合法性、疾控中心建议等方面的问题。坦白说，那次会议没有产生成果，这与他们所希望的对艾滋病毒进行筛查的结果相去甚远。现在，一些估计表明，由于那次会议的失败，又有12,000人因输注了受污染的血液而感染或死亡。因此，利害关系非常重大。数据极其明确。
Unfortunately, the presentation of that data didn't necessarily have the outcome the CDC were hoping for. We've seen different examples of arguments falling short. Nero failed to convince his parents about video games and he failed to convince the PhD committee about the student. The CDC failed to persuade the blood banks to start screening for the AIDS virus. When we come back, the common mistake that undermines the effectiveness of our arguments
不幸的是，这些数据的呈现方式并未能必然带来疾控中心所期望的结果。我们已经看到了论点落空的各种不同例子。尼罗没能说服父母让他玩电子游戏，也没能说服博士委员会录取那个学生。疾控中心没能说服血库开始筛查艾滋病毒。当我们回来时，我们将探讨削弱我们论点有效性的常见错误，
and how to get our ideas to land better. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Nero Sivanathan studies organizational behavior at London Business School. In recent years, he has become fascinated by the way we make arguments and the errors we make in choosing the most effective arguments. So, we've seen a number of examples here nearer, somewhere people are trying to convince someone else of something they probably shouldn't be convincing someone else off, you know, having your parents allow you to play more video games, or trying to convince someone about something that's important, you know, getting the PhD student admitted into
以及如何让我们的观点更好地被理解。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。尼罗·西瓦纳坦在伦敦商学院研究组织行为学。近年来，他开始对我们提出论点的方式以及我们在选择最有效论点时所犯的错误着迷。所以，我们在尼罗这里看到了许多例子，有些情况下人们试图说服别人做一些他们可能不应该说服别人的事，你知道的，让你的父母允许你玩更多电子游戏，或者试图说服别人相信某件重要的事情，（比如）让博士生被
the program, or for the CDC, you know, getting the blood bank organizations to think about the transmission of HIV through the blood supply. You say that there is a common mistake in many of these examples that we are seeing and you call this mistake the dilution effect. What is this, Nero? The dilution effect or what's commonly referred to as the argument dilution effect is broadly a phenomenon, Shankar, which is where you, when never making an argument or whenever trying to articulate a point, oftentimes people give supporting arguments. And whenever you add in weak arguments, it dilutes away from your very strong argument.
项目录取，或者对疾控中心而言，让血库组织考虑经由血液供应传播艾滋病毒的问题。你说在我们看到的许多例子中都有一个共同的错误，你将这个错误称为“稀释效应”。这是什么，尼罗？稀释效应，或者通常被称为论点稀释效应，广泛来讲是一种现象，尚卡尔，即当你提出论点或试图阐明某个观点时，人们往往会给出支持性论据。而每当你加入薄弱的论据时，它就会削弱你非常有力的论点。
Put another way, when you add extraneous information to your central point, the extra stuff isn't just fluff that gets ignored by the person you are trying to convince. The extra stuff actually undermines the point you are trying to make. In fact, even when a piece of information is not extraneous, but just slightly off the mark, it has the effect of undermining the strongest portion of your argument. Neurosess One Place This Happens is when lawyers present eyewitness testimony in court.
换句话说，当你在核心观点中添加不相关的信息时，多余的内容不仅仅是被你试图说服的人忽视的废话。这些多余的内容实际上会破坏你试图表达的观点。事实上，即使一条信息并非完全不相关，而只是稍微有些偏差，它也会起到破坏你论中最有力部分的效果。尼罗指出，这种情况发生的一个场景是律师在法庭上出示目击者证词。
So this was a study that was done several years ago where imagine a scenario, Shankar, where you are the prosecution, you've got a couple of choices to make, you've got a very good eyewitness who saw the suspect and has a very clear account of what they saw. And you have another eyewitness testimony from another individual who saw the individual didn't get a clear image of this person, but certainly the elements that they saw fit the description of the suspect. Now, the typical calculus that someone might make
这是一项几年前进行的研究，设想这样一个场景，尚卡尔，假设你是控方，你必须做出几个选择：你有一个非常好的目击者，他看到了嫌疑人，并且对自己看到的情况有着非常清晰的描述。而你还有另一位目击者的证词，来自另一个人，他看到了这个人，但没有看清这个人的清晰形象，不过他看到的要素确实符合嫌疑人的描述。现在，人们通常会做出的计算
is to think, look, I've got one very strong eyewitness, but I also have a second eyewitness that sort of corroborates it, although they have some doubt. Turns out that presenting both of those eyewitnesses in support of the prosecution dilutes the overall strength. Even though as a forecast, you might believe, look, I've got two eyewitnesses. When, in fact, the weaker eyewitness dilutes the overall strength, if you will, of the argument made by the prosecution. Nero, in general, if something is good, more of it is better.
是认为：看哪，我有一个非常强有力的目击者，但我也有一个第二个目击者来作为某种程度的佐证，尽管他们有一些疑虑。事实证明，在控方的支持下同时出示这两位目击者会削弱整体的证明力。尽管作为预测，你可能会相信：看，我有两个目击者。但事实上，较弱的目击者会稀释控方所提论点的整体力量。尼罗，一般来说，如果某个东西是好的，那么越多越好。
So getting free lunch for a month is better than getting free lunches for a week, making more money feels better than making less. So when it comes to persuading other people, we gravitate quite naturally to the same logic. If one piece of evidence is persuasive, surely ten pieces of evidence should be even more convincing. Why would this not be the case? The great question, Shankar and I think this is a forecasting error that we make when we communicate, perhaps extrapolating from that very logic, right? More money is better than less, more free cups of coffee is better than less. In the world of influence and more specifically
所以连续一个月吃免费午餐比吃一周免费午餐要好，赚更多钱感觉比赚得少要好。因此，在说服其他人时，我们很自然地会倾向于同样的逻辑。如果一条证据具有说服力，那么十条证据肯定会更有说服力。为什么情况并非如此呢？这是一个极好的问题，尚卡尔，我认为这是我们在沟通过程中犯下的预测错误，也许是从那种逻辑中进行了外推，对吧？更多的钱比更少的好，更多杯免费咖啡比更少的好。在影响力的世界里，更具体地说是
communicating for the purpose of influence, that logic or that calculus is an erroneous one to subscribe to. To demonstrate this idea, Nero asked me to think about how to make an effective argument. Let's say you want to convince someone that the French soccer star, Killian in Bappe, is the best soccer player in the world. And let's assume you've come up with four reasons or four arguments for why Embape is the best football player. Let's assume of these four arguments you've come up with. Two of them are very strong, and they're worth,
为了影响力而进行的沟通中，这种逻辑或计算方式是一种错误的信奉。为了展示这个想法，尼罗让我思考如何提出一个有说服力的论点。假设你想说服某人，法国足球明星基利安·姆巴佩是世界上最好的足球运动员。假设你已经想出了四个理由或四个论点来解释为什么姆巴佩是最好的足球运动员。假设在你提出的这四个论点中。其中两个非常强有力，在论点强度上，它们值得
let's say, 90 points out of 100 in terms of argument strength. So these are incredibly strong arguments, and they're worth 90 points out of 100. So let's say, in Bappé's chord, many goals, for example, or he is much more consistent in the way he scores goals. Those could be very strong arguments to make the case that he is the best soccer player in the world. Indeed, right?
比如满分100分中的90分。所以这些是极其强有力的论点，在100分中值90分。因此，比如说，姆巴佩进了很多球，或者他在进球方式上要稳定得多。这些都是非常有力的论点，可以证明他是世界上最好的足球运动员。确实如此，对吧？
And let's assume you come up with two additional arguments that are very good, but not as strong as the first two, and only worth 60 points out of 100. These could be such things as he plays for the very best team in France. He signed a great contract, so forth. The calculus that most communicators make and previewed by your earlier comment is to think, look, I've got four great arguments. Grand to two of them are very strong, but the other two are still strong. Let me put it all on the table as a way to convince Neuro that M-Bop A is the best football
假设你又想出了另外两个非常优秀但不如前两个那么强有力的论点，在100分中只值60分。这些论点可能是诸如他效力于法国最好的球队、他签了一份优厚的合同之类的事情。大多数沟通者所做的计算，正如你早先的评论所预示的那样，是认为：看，我有四个很棒的论点。固然其中有两个非常强有力，但另外两个依然很强。让我把它们全部摆在桌面上，以此来说服尼罗姆巴佩是最好的足球
player. The calculus that you're making, Shankar, is that the strength of that argument is 300 points, 90 plus 90 plus 60 plus 60. Turns out, however, receivers of information don't engage in an additive function, they engage in an averaging function. An averaging function. The two weaker arguments are not piling on top of the stronger arguments to make a taller tower. Instead, the weaker arguments are undermining the stronger ones.
运动员。尚卡尔，你所做的计算是，该论点的强度是300分，即90加90加60加60。然而事实证明，信息的接收者并不进行加法运算，他们进行的是平均值运算。平均值运算。这两个较弱的论点并没有叠加在较强的论点之上来建造一座更高的塔。相反，较弱的论点削弱了较强的论点。
If you're keeping track of the math, we have four arguments that are collectively worth 300 points. That means the average score across the four arguments is 75 points. Now, if you want to be more persuasive and more influential, you will be far better off to say, Nero, Mbappé is the very best football player in the world because of reason one, reason two, stop. Now I hear 90 plus 90 adds up to 180 divided by 2. Strength of that argument is 90 points, not 75. In the world of influence, unlike free coffees, etc., is that the strength of any argument that you make is only as strong as your weakest link.
如果你在做数学计算，我们有四个论点，总共价值300分。这意味着这四个论点的平均分是75分。现在，如果你想更具说服力和影响力，你最好这样说：“尼罗，姆巴佩是世界上最好的足球运动员，因为原因一，原因二，停下。”现在我听到90加90等于180，除以2。该论点的强度是90分，而不是75分。在影响力的世界里，与免费咖啡等不同的是，你提出的任何论点的强度仅取决于你最薄弱的环节。
This is what happened when Nero was advocating for the PhD candidate. He would likely have been better off if he had simply said, this candidate has off-the-wall talent in terms of research. No one else comes even close. Instead, in trying to anticipate potential lines of criticism from other committee members, Nearled through and supporting arguments about how the candidates' weaker grades were not that important and that they involved more difficult courses. The committee's discussion soon focused on the weaker grades instead
这就是尼罗在为博士候选人辩护时发生的情况。如果他当时简单地说“这位候选人在研究方面具有非凡的天赋，没有人能望其项背”，他可能会做得更好。相反，在试图预测来自其他委员会成员潜在的批评路线时，尼罗冗长地阐述了支持性论点，解释了候选人较低的成绩其实并不那么重要，而且他们选修的是更具挑战性的课程。委员会的讨论很快就集中在了较弱的成绩上，
of the stellar research. Like all psychological phenomena, the argument dilution effect can have good consequences and bad consequences. It can keep a bad politician from implementing bad policies or it can allow people into a false sense of security. Think about the pharmaceutical ads that are ubiquitous on American television. And the typical architecture of these ads is you'll see a happy couple dancing and prancing through their back garden or the park because for the first time in months they were able to get a full night's sleep. But because of FDA regulations that were passed down about 20, 20 plus years ago,
而不是出色的研究成果上。像所有心理学现象一样，论点稀释效应既会带来积极的结果，也会带来消极的结果。它既可以阻止一个糟糕的政客实施糟糕的政策，也可能让人们陷入虚假的安全感中。想想美国电视上无处不在的制药广告。这些广告的典型架构是：你会看到一对幸福的夫妇在后花园或公园里翩翩起舞，因为几个月来他们第一次能够睡个好觉。但由于大约20年前通过的FDA法规，
the last 30 seconds of that one minute ad needs to be devoted to the side effects of that drug. And so what you'll typically hear is a hurried voiceover that says, side effects include heart attack, stroke, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, and we'll end with something like itchy feet. Guess what itchy feet does to the average consumers evaluation of the risk associated with that drug? Am I now averaging out strokes and hard disease and itchy feet and putting them all together in the same bucket in my mind? That is correct.
那段一分钟广告的最后30秒必须留给该药物的副作用。所以你通常会听到一个急促的画外音说：“副作用包括心脏病发作、中风，巴拉巴拉巴拉”，最后以诸如“足部瘙痒”之类的内容结束。你猜足部瘙痒会对普通消费者对该药物相关风险的评估产生什么影响？我是不是现在把中风、心脏病和足部瘙痒平均起来，把它们全归入我脑海中的同一个篮子里了？完全正确。
The itchy feet dilute people's overall risk assessment of heart attack. Imagine an alternate commercial, Shankar, which is, it says, this drug cures your sleep problems, side effects are heart attack and stroke. Now all of us in your thinking, I don't mind staying up the rest of my life. Turns out this sort of FDA regulation, which was done for very noble reasons, which is they wanted pharmaceutical companies to be transparent with both the benefits, but also the cost. But turns out listing a shopping list of side effects, both major side effects, such as heart attack
足部瘙痒稀释了人们对心脏病发作的整体风险评估。尚卡尔，想象一下另一则广告，它说：“这种药能解决你的睡眠问题，副作用是心脏病发作和中风。”现在，你们所有人都会想：“我宁愿余生都熬夜。”事实证明，这种FDA的规定原本是出于非常崇高的目的，即他们希望制药公司对益处和成本都保持透明。但事实证明，列出一长串副作用清单——既有心脏病发作和中风等主要副作用，
and stroke, coupled with some minor side effects, such as itchy feet, long toenails, etc., dilute people's overall risk assessment of that drug. Now you'll notice here, Shankar, this isn't non-diagnostic information, it is simply that even weak diagnostic information dilutes people's overall evaluation. Nero wanted to take a deeper look at this phenomenon. He ran a series of studies in which he tried to mimic a typical pharmaceutical ad. In one study, Nero and his team showed people a full list of side effects for a sleep drug. In another, neuro-nestime removed three of the weakest side effects from the
又夹杂着足部瘙痒、趾甲长长等一些次要副作用——会稀释人们对该药物整体风险的评估。现在你会注意到，尚卡尔，这不是非诊断性信息，只是即使是微弱的诊断性信息也会稀释人们的整体评估。尼罗希望更深入地研究这种现象。他开展了一系列研究，试图模仿典型的制药广告。在一项研究中，尼罗和他的团队向人们展示了某种睡眠药的全部副作用列表。在另一项研究中，尼罗的团队从广告中删除了三个最弱的副作用。
ad. In other words, volunteers were only shown the major side effects. And what we find is that individuals who are exposed just to the major side effects, rather than the complete list of side effects, evaluated the severity of the side effects, overall severity to be much lower. When they saw the full list of side effects, they raided the drug to be more effective, and even in one study, were willing to pay more for that drug than the version that only listed the major side effects. I was called for jury duty a couple of weeks ago, and I went there, but I was not selected, and I was at the courthouse and didn't have
换句话说，志愿者们只看到了主要的副作用。我们发现，仅接触主要副作用而不是完整副作用列表的个人，对副作用严重程度（整体严重程度）的评估要低得多。当他们看到完整的副作用列表时，他们对该药物有效性的评价更高，甚至在其中一项研究中，他们愿意为该药物支付比仅列出主要副作用的版本更高的价格。我几周前接到过陪审团的传唤，我去了，但没有被选中。当时我在法院，那天早上我的日程安排不是很满。
very much on my calendar that morning. So I decided to stop by a murder trial for a couple of hours. And I noticed something very interesting, which is as the prosecutor was making her case, it seemed like a very compelling case. The circumstantial evidence was very strong. The video footage was very strong. And I was like, this is the prosecutor is probably right. And then the defense council started speaking. And one of the things he did was he just added a lot more detail to what was going on, just a lot more information.
所以我决定去旁听几个小时的谋杀案审判。我注意到一个非常有趣的现象，即当检察官陈述案情时，这似乎是一个非常令人信服的案情。间接证据非常充分。视频素材非常充分。当时我想：检察官可能是对的。然后辩护律师开始发言。他所做的事情之一就是为正在发生的事情增添了大量细节，仅仅是大量更多信息。
And the more detail he added, the weaker the prosecutors' arguments seem to become. So it's almost a variation of what you're talking about, which is that when we have a large volume of information coming at us, our minds somehow tend to average out that information rather than looking at only this most salient pieces of information. That's right. We've talked about how to be more persuasive and more influential. And so one of the areas that individuals often make is to list a shopping list of benefits for why imbap is the best player or a founder might list all the benefits of his new startup over
他添加的细节越多，检察官的论点似乎就越显得薄弱。所以这几乎是你所谈论的内容的一种变体，即当大量的信息向我们涌来时，我们的头脑往往会不知何故地对这些信息进行平均处理，而不是仅仅关注那些最突出的信息片段。没错。我们已经讨论了如何变得更具说服力和影响力。因此，人们经常犯的错误之一是列出一长串理由来证明姆巴佩是最佳球员，或者创始人可能会列出他的新初创公司相对于市场上现有产品的全部好处。
what's currently on the market. But in lots of settings, Shankar, you also need to highlight both the pros, but also the cons. And in the various takeaway from this or a way to abuse this is one way in which to get individuals not to focus on the negatives is to dilute it with a lot of trivial negative elements with that product. So you can imagine a financial product. In fact, this didn't make it into our study, but we did run this where we provided a financial instrument or a financial product. product and in one we listed some of the major risk factors associated with this product and others we listed both the major but also some of the minor risk factors. And when you list the minor risk factors people rate that financial product to be less
但在许多情况下，尚卡尔，你还需要同时突出优点和缺点。其中的各种应对方法或利用这一点的方法是，让人不去关注消极因素的一种方法，是用该产品大量琐碎的消极元素来稀释它。所以你可以想象一个金融产品。事实上，这没有进入我们的研究，但我们确实进行了这项测试，我们提供了一种金融工具或金融产品，在一项测试中我们列出了与该产品相关的一些主要风险因素，而在其他测试中我们既列出了主要风险因素，也列出了一些次要风险因素。当你列出次要风险因素时，人们会认为该金融产品风险更小，而不是风险更大，并且更愿意消费该产品。
risky, not more risky and willing to consume that product. All as a result of the dilution effect. I asked Nero why the dilution effect occurs. Was it simply a matter of being inundated with too much information? Multiple strands of social science research have shown that humans are so-called cognitive measures. We constantly seek to simplify the amount of thinking we have to do. Give us lots of different points, and instead of carefully tallying up the sum, we simply generate a rough average of all the points. Nero said that while that hypothesis was plausible, the data did not support it.
这一切都是稀释效应的结果。我问尼罗为什么会出现稀释效应。这仅仅是因为信息过载吗？多项社会科学研究表明，人类是所谓的“认知守财奴”。我们不断寻求简化我们必须进行的思考。给我们提供许多不同的观点，我们不是仔细计算总和，而是简单地对所有观点生成一个粗略的平均值。尼罗说，虽然这个假设听起来很 plausibel（合理），但数据并不支持它。
We, in fact, ran several studies where we limited the amount of information people were exposed to. So in fact, we listed just the major side effects and just the minor side effects as well as the complete side effects. And what you see is that counter to a information overload account. What you find is that controlling for the amount of information one is asked to process. find is that controlling for the amount of information one is asked to process, when individuals are given both major and minor, people rate that drug to be less risky and less severity in its side effects than information, which is just the major side effects or just the minor side effects. So this is fascinating because I think what I'm hearing you say is that in some ways there are two
事实上，我们进行了几项研究，限制了人们接触的信息量。因此，我们实际上仅列出了主要副作用、仅列出了次要副作用，以及完整的副作用。你所看到的是，与信息过载的解释相反。你发现的是，在控制了被要求处理的信息量的情况下，当个人同时获得主要和次要信息时，人们对该药物风险及其副作用严重程度的评价，竟然比只提供主要副作用信息或只提供次要副作用信息时还要低和轻。所以这很迷人，因为我认为我听到你所说的是，在某些方面存在两个
problems, but they might also be related problems. The first problem is just the volume of information that's coming at us can be so great that we can basically shut down and say I can't take in any more information, which is your standard information overload argument. But there's a second argument, which I think is in some ways a more subtle and insidious form of this of this problem, which is that the volume of information coming at me is not overwhelming, but the information is of varying quality and my mind is not very good at assigning different weights to the different qualities of information coming in. And so I do the cognitively simpler thing of actually averaging out everything and assuming everything is the same. Instead of doing the more cognitively
问题，但它们也可能是相关的问题。第一个问题仅仅是向我们涌来的信息量可能如此巨大，以至于我们基本上会关闭大脑，说我再也吸收不了任何信息了，这就是你标准的信息过载论点。但第二个论点，我认为在某些方面是该问题一种更微妙、更隐蔽的形式，那就是向我涌来的信息量并没有压倒一切，但信息的质量参差不齐，而我的大脑并不擅长为涌入的不同质量信息分配不同的权重。所以我做了认知上更简单的处理，实际上把一切都平均化了，并假设一切都是一样的。而不是去做认知上
difficult thing of saying this piece of information is worth a lot more than this other piece of information. Does that sound fair? That is correct. And if there are steps that could be done to recategorize them. And that somehow in my mind, I say, this is a different category of information than this. Again, the dilution effect occurs, but the weight has been shifted as a result of increasing focus or creating a distinction between these two categories of information. So I'll give you an example of this chunk or so in the pharmaceutical ads, one of the things we did in one of the studies is we took the the major side effects we put that in red font and bold and the minor side effects we left it in black ink and regular font. In other words, Nero and his team gave volunteers the same volume of information about side effects.
更困难的事情，即说这块信息比那块信息价值大得多。这听起来公平吗？完全正确。如果可以采取步骤对它们进行重新分类。以某种方式在我的脑海中，我说，这是与此不同类别的信息。同样，稀释效应发生了，但由于增加了焦点或在这两类信息之间建立了区别，权重已经发生了转移。我给你举个例子，尚卡尔，在制药广告中，我们在其中一项研究所做的事情之一是，我们将主要的副作用用红色字体和粗体显示，而次要副作用我们用黑色墨水和常规字体。换句话说，尼罗和他的团队给志愿者提供了关于副作用的相同量的信息。
But for one group, they made the major side effects pop out. Volunteers were being told, pay more attention to these side effects. So we haven't changed the content or the data. But by simply doing that, what we see is that consumers, or in this case, are participants still engaged in the averaging effect, but the impact of that averaging effect is now reduced as a result. And there's still a dilution, but I've now given greater weight to the first two, less weight to the second two, and as a result, the overall impact of that message is closer to the outcome you're hoping for. And again, you're not overcoming the averaging effect, you're just helping reduce its impact.
但对于其中一组，他们让主要的副作用突显出来。志愿者被告知：多注意这些副作用。所以我们没有改变内容或数据。但仅仅通过这样做，我们看到的是消费者，或者在这个案例中，参与者仍然参与了平均效应，但现在该平均效应的影响因此降低了。仍然存在稀释，但我现在赋予前两个更大的权重，赋予后两个更小的权重，因此该消息的总体影响更接近你所希望的结果。而且，你并没有克服平均效应，你只是在帮助减少其影响。
In 1969, Fred Rogers testified before Congress to secure more funding for public broadcasting. Neenu, I understand that you teach about Mr. Rogers' testimony in your class. Give me the context of that event and what happened next. Yeah, so this was a testimony in front of Congress. Various individuals had presented Copius amounts of data for why it should not be funded, lots of testimonies, etc. And what you hear there is Fred Rogers moves away from a shopping list of reasons or data points for why PBS should be funded.
1969年，弗雷德·罗杰斯在国会作证，为公共广播争取更多资金。尼罗，我听说你在课堂上讲授罗杰斯先生的证词。请告诉我该事件的背景以及接下来发生了什么。是的，这是在国会面前的证词。各种个人提交了大量的数据，说明为什么不应该资助它，有大量的证词等。你在那里听到的是，弗雷德·罗杰斯摆脱了为什么PBS应该获得资助的一长串理由或数据点的束缚。
Fred Rogers does multiple things during that testimony that is really a master class on communicating for the purpose of influence. He has one key argument, a pretty potent one, and one that very clearly pulls on the heart strings, and he does not deviate from it. He could have come up with 10 other things that kids benefit from his programming. He sticks to a very core element and provides one vivid example of that main point. And the rest is history, as I say. Nero says he has been on a mission to make people aware of the argument dilution effect. But as a parent himself, there are also times where the dilution effect helps him see through a weak case.
在这次证词期间，弗雷德·罗杰斯做了多项事情，堪称为了影响力而进行沟通的大师级范例。他有一个核心论点，相当强有力，并且能非常清晰地触动心弦，而且他没有偏离这一点。他本可以想出其他10个孩子从他的节目中受益的好处。他坚持一个非常核心的要素，并为该主要观点提供了一个生动的例子。正如我所说，剩下的就是历史了。尼罗说，他一直在执行一项使命，让人们意识到论点稀释效应。但作为一名父亲，有时稀释效应也帮助他看穿了薄弱的辩解。
Some time ago, Nero's son made the argument that he needed to stay home from school one day. I think this was about a year ago, my son woke up and had complained that he was in feeling well and needed to stay home. And, you know, as with any parent you're obviously concerned that they're okay. And so once we've sort of had that initial discussion, kind of asked him to explain what his symptoms were, which started with, you know, I'm not feeling well, my tummy isn't feeling well. I think I also have a bit of a headache. I've also feel like I'm getting
不久前，尼罗的儿子提出了他某一天需要留在家里的理由。我想这大约是一年前，我儿子醒来后抱怨说他感觉身体不舒服，需要留在家。你知道的，作为任何父母，你显然会担心他们是否安好。因此，在我们进行初步讨论后，要求他解释他的症状是什么，他首先说的是：“我感觉不舒服，我的肚子感觉不舒服。我想我也有点头痛。我还觉得我正在发
a little bit of fever. That was then followed with, I think, my leg is hurting a little bit too. I'm also having some blurred vision and a whole lot of other symptoms which suggest that one would have thought, my son had Ebola, but certainly he didn't. But he listed off a string of symptoms that he was experiencing or felt like he was a bent experience. So he presented the case that he was close to death's door basically. Pretty much, yeah. So I think that death was sort of knocking at his bedroom door and just a day of staying home
一点烧。”紧接着他说的是：“我想我的腿也有一点疼。我的视线也有些模糊”以及一连串其他症状，让人觉得，我儿子好像得了埃博拉病毒一样，但当然他并没有。但他列出了一连串他正在经历或感觉自己正在经历的症状。因此他提出的情况是，他基本上已经一只脚踏进了鬼门关。差不多是这样。所以我想死神似乎在敲他卧室的门，而只要在家里待上一天
would help overcome these numerous symptoms. Nero did what his parents had done to him when he tried to make the case that playing video games would help him to learn French. He didn't buy it. When we come back, we look at the challenges of communication, not from the point of view of the communicator, but the point of view of the audience.
就能帮助克服这些无数的症状。尼罗做了他的父母当年在他试图证明玩电子游戏能帮他学法语时对他做过的事。他根本不买账。当我们回来时，我们将探讨沟通所面临的挑战，不是从沟通者的角度，而是从受众的角度。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We live in extraordinary times. Information is more accessible than it's ever been at any point in human history. If you want to know the current temperature in a city halfway around the planet, you can find out with a quick Google search. If you're curious about the name of a star, you're watching in the night sky, an app can tell you what it is.
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们生活在一个非凡的时代。在人类历史上的任何时期，信息都从未像现在这样触手可及。如果你想知道地球另一端某个城市的当前温度，通过一次快速的谷歌搜索就能找到答案。如果你对夜空中正在观察的一颗星星的名字感到好奇，一个应用程序就能告诉你它是什么。
But the easy and endless availability of information is not always a blessing. Brian Matlowflin remembers getting obsessed with information during the 2020 presidential election in the United States. Every minor change in the polls, every statement and counter-statement between candidates Donald Trump and Joe Biden became cause for sleepless nights. For me, a lot of it was Twitter, right? And I ended up just on my phone all the time for, you
但信息的轻松且无休止的获取并不总是一件幸事。布赖恩·马特劳林回忆起在2020年美国总统大选期间对信息的痴迷。民调的每一个微小变化，候选人唐纳德·特朗普和乔·拜登之间的每一份声明和反声明，都成了失眠夜的诱因。对当时的很多我来说，主要是Twitter，对吧？结果我基本上整天都抱着手机，在
know, a few months leading up to the election, just trying to get new tidbits of information and just kind of always finding myself kind of just hooked into it, thinking about all the time, having trouble sleeping, just definitely stressed and anxious about things, just following kind of every move in terms of what the candidatesis were saying, how it's being received, things of that nature. And why do you think you were doing that? What were you aiming to get out of it? I was aiming to ease my anxiety about the potential outcome.
你知道的，选举前的几个月里，只是试图获取新的信息碎片，发现自己总是深陷其中，满脑子都在想这件事，难以入眠，对各种事情感到压力重重、焦虑不安，只是关注候选人们在说什么、外界如何反应以及诸如此类的每一个举动。你觉得你当时为什么要这么做？你希望从中得到什么？我希望以此缓解我对潜在结果的焦虑。
I just, you know, pretty concerned about, you know, how things could go and I was anxious about it and I wanted to find information that would maybe make me feel a bit better about it. But the information Brian sought did not soothe his anxiety. His obsession with the news cycle started to affect his personal life. I call just, you know, a time that I'm on the floor, in my kids' room, I should be playing with him. He's trying to get my attention and I I'm just on my phone, checking Twitter, kind of having a hard time putting it down. And I kind of realize that, you know, I'm really disconnected here,
我只是，你知道的，非常关心事情会如何发展，为此感到焦虑，我想找到一些能让我感觉好一点的信息。但布赖恩寻找的信息并没有平息他的焦虑。他对新闻循环的痴迷开始影响他的个人生活。我记得有一次，我坐在我孩子房间的地板上，我本该陪他玩。他正试图引起我的注意，而我却一直在看Twitter，很难放下手机。我突然意识到，你知道的，我在这里彻底与世隔绝了，
that I'm not paying attention to my son, not playing with him. I'm trying to sneak in this time and I've kind of, it's really being disruptive. Brian would interrupt conversations with his wife to check the news. And you should be like, seriously? Like, I'm literally talking to you right now, and you're going to get on your phone. But I had a hard time helping it, right? I just, it just became so second nature that I kind of wouldn't even think about it.
我没有关注我的儿子，也没有陪他玩。我只是试图偷闲来看手机，这真的带来了很大的干扰。布赖恩会打断与妻子的谈话去看新闻。而她会说：‘认真的吗？我正跟你面对面说话呢，你又要看手机。’但我很难克制自己，对吧？这已经成了我的一种下意识反应，我甚至都不会去想它。
I would just, out of habit, pull out my phone just to check. Tell me what effect this had on your physical and mental health, this sort of obsession with Twitter and what was happening with the election? I definitely started off with a lot of sleep issues, just kind of waking up in the middle of the night and not being able to go to bed. I remember kind of laying down in bed and just noticing how tense my body was, how clenched up my muscles were, just kind of feeling a lot of physical stress. I developed back pain, and I had it for months after that,
我只是出于习惯掏出手机看一眼。请告诉我，这种对Twitter和选举动态的痴迷，对你的身心健康产生了什么影响？我的睡眠确实出了很多问题，比如在半夜醒来后就再也睡不着了。我记得躺在床上时，能明显感觉到身体有多紧绷，肌肉有多僵硬，能真切感受到巨大的身体压力。我得了背痛，之后的几个月一直都有，
where I just every day dealt with back pain. As a communications researcher at Texas Tech University, Brian got curious about whether his experience was idiosyncratic. In 2021, he and his colleagues conducted a study asking people about their news habits. They discovered multiple factors that characterize what he calls harmful news consumption. Yeah, so me and my co-authors, Melissa Gottlieb and Devon Mills, we developed this idea of with the Gottlieb and Devin Millas, we kind of developed this idea of problem-backed news consumption, which is similar to this idea of news addiction, but we don't think it's technically addiction.
每天都要忍受背痛的折磨。作为德克萨斯理工大学的一名传播学研究员，布赖恩开始好奇自己的经历是否只是个例。2021年，他和同事们进行了一项研究，询问人们的新闻习惯。他们发现了多个特征，用他的话说，这些特征构成了有害的新闻消费。是的，我和我的合著者梅丽莎·戈特利布和德文·米尔斯，我们提出了一个概念，与戈特利布和德文·米尔斯一起，我们提出了问题驱动的新闻消费这个概念，这类似于新闻成瘾的概念，但我们认为它在技术上并非成瘾。
And then we did a survey with over, I think, 1100 U.S. adults. And we looked at their overall news use, but then we developed these different components of problem-backed news consumption, which include transportation, the extent to which they're drawn into the news. Preoccupation, the extent to which they're thinking about it all the time. So even after a new stop consuming the news, they just can't stop thinking about it. Misregulation, which is the idea that people keep going back to the news thinking it might make them feel better, even though ultimately it doesn't. Underregulation, which is like the inability to stop, they just need to do it all the
然后我们做了一项调查，对象涵盖了超过1100名美国成年人。我们考察了他们整体的新闻使用情况，然后开发了问题驱动新闻消费的不同组成部分，包括运载性，即他们被新闻吸引的程度；专注度，即他们无时无刻不在思考新闻的程度，也就是说，即使在停止获取新闻之后，他们也停不下来思考；错误调节，即人们不断返回新闻，认为这可能会让他们感觉更好，尽管最终并没有；调节不足，类似于无法停止，他们就是需要一直这样做，
time. And then interference, the extent of which it starts bleeding into and affecting other aspects of your life, like spending time with family, paying attention to work. And so we looked at these components, we found they all kind of worked together as a cohesive, concept, problematic news consumption. And we looked at that in the relationship to mental and physical health, while also controlling kind of work together as a cohesive concept, problem-ack news consumption. And we looked at that in the relationship to mental and physical health,
还有干扰性，即它开始渗透并影响你生活其他方面的程度，比如陪伴家人、专注工作。我们考察了这些组成部分，发现它们作为一个有凝聚力的概念——问题驱动新闻消费，协同发挥作用。我们将这一点与身心健康的关系进行了研究，同时控制了总体新闻使用等因素，作为问题驱动新闻消费的一个有凝聚力的概念共同起作用。我们考察了它与身心健康的关系，
while also controlling for things like overall news use. And we found a very strong relationship between those who had the highest levels of problem-ack news consumption and worse mental and physical health. So one of the striking things in your study is that you found that nearly half the people in your sample, I think it was about 43%, had symptoms that were either what you call moderately problematic or severely problematic. That's astonishing, Brian. It was definitely higher than we expected.
同时控制了总体新闻使用等因素。我们发现，问题驱动新闻消费水平最高的人，其身心健康状况更差，两者之间存在非常强的关联。你研究中最引人注目的一点是，你发现样本中将近一半的人，大概43%的人，其症状属于你所说的中度或严重问题。这太惊人了，布赖恩。这确实比我们预期的要高。
And I think, part of it might have just been timing, right? We did this, you know, right after the election, still during the midst of the pandemic. So, maybe people were a little bit more tuned in and stressed out than normal. But still, it's pretty wide phenomenon. And almost without fail, somebody says, oh, that's just like my aunt, or I can identify with that. So percentages are definitely higher than we expected, but also I think that we see a lot of anecdotal evidence of this as well. So the most disturbing aspect of what you found, of course, was the connections between people who are absorbing excessive amounts of the news and their
我想，部分原因可能只是时机问题，对吧？我们做这项调查时，正好是在大选刚结束之后，而且正值疫情期间。所以，人们可能比平时更加关注、压力也更大。但即便如此，这仍然是一个非常广泛的现象。几乎毫无例外，总有人会说：‘哦，这太像我阿姨了，’或者‘我也有同感。’所以比例确实比我们预期的要高，但我也认为我们在现实中看到了很多这方面的轶事证据。当然，你发现中最令人不安的方面，是那些过度吸收新闻的人与他们的
physical and mental wellbeing. What kind of symptoms were you, what people's reporting, Brian? So for mental well-being, we were looking at anxiety and stress, how frequently do you experience things like panic, feeling stressed out? And so, the higher levels of generalized stress and anxiety in terms of mental well-being. For physical well-being, we looked at things like headaches, GI issues, back pain, neck pain. And so we kind of collapsed those just overall incidents of kind of physical ill-being. I think it's kind of remarkable that you're finding that there's a connection between
身心健康之间的联系。布赖恩，人们都报告了哪些症状？在心理健康方面，我们考察的是焦虑和压力，你经历恐慌、感到压力的频率有多高？因此，在心理健康方面表现为更高水平的广泛性压力和焦虑。在身体健康方面，我们考察了头痛、胃肠道问题、背痛、颈痛等。因此，我们将这些总体身体不适的事件进行了归类。我觉得很了不起的是，你发现
over-consumption of news and these physical and mental symptoms, right? I mean, reading the newspaper or watching cable television is not like getting exposed to COVID, it's not a pathogen, but it seems to be having effects on our health very much like a pathogen. There's a good example. In nature, like gazelles, like when they see a lion,
过度消费新闻与这些身心症状之间存在关联，对吧？我的意思是，读报纸或看有线电视并不像感染新冠病毒，它不是一种病原体，但它对我们健康产生的影响却非常像病原体。这里有一个很好的例子。在自然界中，比如羚羊，当它们看到狮子时，
everything shoots up, they run away, everything's on high alert, then once they're safe, everything goes back to normal, they continue grazing, and it's like nothing ever happened. And so that case, the physical reaction, the physiological reaction is helpful, it helps you do what you need, then you can go back with your life. People who are stuck in the news though,
各项指标飙升，它们逃跑，一切都处于高度戒备状态；一旦它们安全了，一切恢复正常，它们继续吃草，就像什么都没发生过一样。所以在这种情况下，身体反应、生理反应是有益的，它能帮你完成你需要做的事，然后你就能回归生活。然而，那些沉迷于新闻的人，
and they can't stop thinking about it, it kind of never goes down. Because you were just always thinking about it, either we're reading it, we're watching it, it kind of never goes down. Right? Because you were just always thinking about it. Either we're reading it or watching it, or we're just thinking about it. And if we have a high level of perceived threat, if we're very anxious, if our cortisol is high, we can suffer inflammation, and that can really take a toll on our bodies. I mean, I love the analogy because imagine now that Gazelle is basically being exposed to the lion, you know, 16 hours a day, seven days a week. Right.
而且无法停止思考，这种状态就永远不会消退。因为你总是想着它，无论是在阅读还是观看，它似乎永远不会结束。对吧？因为你总是在想它。要么我们在阅读或观看，要么我们只是在脑子里想。如果我们有很高的感知威胁水平，如果我们非常焦虑，如果我们的皮质醇水平很高，我们就会遭受炎症的折磨，这会对我们的身体造成极大的损害。我的意思是，我太喜欢这个比喻了，因为想象一下，那只羚羊基本上每天16小时、每周7天都在暴露于狮子的威胁下。没错。
I mean, you couldn't function like that, right? If you're just constantly seeing a lion, then you can't ever relax and then it's just never ending. It does seem that that's problematic. I mean, it seems problematic to be telling people the right approaches to tell people to switch off from the news because clearly the news is telling you things that are important. I mean, so if the gazelle that watches the lion, you know, 16 hours a day, seven days a week, that's not going to be a healthy gazelle, the gazelle that basically says, I'm never
我的意思是，你不可能那样生活，对吧？如果你不断看到狮子，那么你永远无法放松，而且这种状态没完没了。这确实是个问题。我的意思是，告诉人们正确的做法是远离新闻，这似乎是个问题，因为显而易见，新闻里都是重要的事情。所以，如果那只看狮子的羚羊，你知道的，每天16小时，每周7天都在看，那将不会是一只健康的羚羊；而那只基本上说“我绝不
going to pay attention to the lion, is a gazelle that gets eaten very quickly. Yeah, it's not going to last very long. No, absolutely. We don't think the solution is to stop consuming news altogether. The news absolutely is essential to our society, both socially and individually. Right? We have kind of a civic responsibility to know what's going on, to pay attention, to politics and vote and all those things. And so being formed is important in that regard socially, but also individually, things like the pandemic.
去关注狮子”的羚羊，则是一只很快就会被吃掉的羚羊。是的，它活不了多久。不，绝对如此。我们认为解决问题的办法并不是完全停止消费新闻。新闻对我们的社会绝对是必不可少的，无论是在社会层面还是个人层面。对吧？我们有一种公民责任，去了解发生了什么，去关注政治并投票以及所有这些事情。因此，从社会角度来看，了解信息很重要；但从个人角度来看也是如此，比如面对大流行病这样的情况。
If you don't know anything about it, you're not going to be able to take the correct appropriate measures for yourself. So from social and individual perspective, there's a lot of important information, crucial information you need to know. So it's more of a matter of not information, crucial information you need to know. So it's more of a matter of not stopping, but just learning how to do it in a healthier manner. I personally used to be a very big fan of Twitter when it first launched. I found it to be an amazing source of information. It told me about new research being conducted at labs around the world. But a social media has become more gladiatorial and self-referential,
如果你对它一无所知，你就无法为自己采取正确适当的措施。因此，从社会和个人的角度来看，有很多你需要了解的重要信息、关键信息。所以这更多是一个问题，不是停止获取，而是学习如何以更健康的方式去做。我个人在Twitter刚推出时曾是它的超级粉丝。我发现它是一个惊人的信息源。它告诉我世界各地实验室正在进行的新研究。但随着社交媒体变得越来越具有角斗士色彩和自我参照性，
I've gradually changed my new style. I've come to believe that if you want to stay informed, without feeling like your hair is constantly on fire, subscribe to and read a good newspaper or tune into your local public radio station. Cut way back on cable TV and give social media a rest. Call it the curse of the information age. We have built amazing tools to stay informed, stay in touch and to influence one another. As communicators, we want to hold on to the mic and say absolutely everything that is on our minds. As audiences, we sometimes find we cannot look away from the torrent of information that comes hurtling toward us every day.
我逐渐改变了我的新闻风格。我开始相信，如果你想保持知情，又不想觉得自己整天火烧眉毛，那就订阅并阅读一份好报纸，或者收听当地的公共广播电台。大大减少看有线电视的时间，让社交媒体歇一歇。这就是信息时代的诅咒。我们构建了惊人的工具来保持知情、保持联系并相互影响。作为传播人员，我们想要握住话筒，说出我们心里想的绝对所有事情。作为受众，有时我们会发现自己无法将视线从每天汹涌而来的信息洪流中移开。
The answer in both cases is to be more discerning. Discerning about the type of information we share, and discerning about the sources and amount of information that we consume. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy- Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Unsung Hero, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. It's a story from our show, My Unsung Hero. Today's story comes from Sarah Marshall. When Sarah was a teenager, her whole life revolved
在这两种情况下，答案都是要更有辨别力。对我们分享的信息类型要有辨别力，对我们消费的信息来源和数量也要有辨别力。《Hidden Brain》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德维克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行主编。今天的“无名英雄”环节，我们将话筒交给你，我们的听众。这是一个来自我们的节目《我的无名英雄》的故事。今天的节目来自莎拉·马歇尔。莎拉十几岁时，她的整个生活都围绕着
around getting into a good college. She spent a lot of time thinking about what she could do to be the perfect applicant. When she finally did get into her dream school, though, she felt adrift. There was something also remarkable about suddenly being done with that existential question and the amount of pressure that you put on yourself to get in that suddenly it feels
考上一所好大学。她花了大量时间思考自己能做些什么来成为完美的申请者。然而，当她最终考入梦想中的学校时，她却感到迷茫。那种突然摆脱了那个存在主义问题以及为了考上而给自己施加的巨大压力的感觉，也是非同寻常的，以至于突然之间
like the thing that you were aiming for the whole time is less relevant in a way than the fact that you're not scared about making it happen anymore. Like many teenagers, she'd spent so much time shaping herself into the perfect student that she hadn't had time to develop a sense of self. But there was a place where she felt like she could explore who she really was. My freshman year of college, I took my first ever acting class. And the class was in a black box theater. It's a small space. And I think there was something about an acting class
你一直以来的目标，在某种程度上似乎变得不如这样一个事实重要：你不再害怕去实现它了。就像许多青少年一样，她花了太多时间把自己塑造成一个完美的学生，以至于没有时间去培养自我意识。但有一个地方，她觉得可以探索真实的自己。上大学一年级时，我上了生平第一堂表演课。这间教室在一个黑匣子剧场里。那是一个很小的空间。我想，表演课的某种特质
that was some kind of a comfortable or a safe intermediary space for me between being someone who largely had learned how to behave in terms of how to do what you need to do in a classroom and how to meet adults' expectations. But where the expectation is not, you're going to memorize these dates, are you going to do this algebra, or you're going to write this essay, but you are going to show up as yourself.
对我来说是一个舒适或安全的中间空间，介于某种人之间：这种人主要学会了如何在行为上做到符合课堂上的要求，如何满足成年人的期望；而在表演课上，期望不是“你要背熟这些日期”、“你要做这个代数题”或者“你要写这篇论文”，而是“你要以真实的自我出现”。
And I just remember a particular moment, probably midway through or near the end of this course, when I was doing an improv scene. And I remember this acting professor, Dina giving us notes and this moment where she said to me, you're, you're funny, you're shy, but you're funny. And for me, it was a moment of being recognized in a very matter of fact way for the thing that I knew I was and least wanted to be, and the thing that I most wanted to be and hoped that I was. And the idea of being witnessed by an adult who wasn't doing it in a way of this is good, this is bad, this is acceptable or this
我只记得一个特定的时刻，大概是在这门课进行到中期或快结束时，我正在做一个即兴表演场景。我记得表演教授迪娜给我们讲评，当时她对我说：“你，你很害羞，但你很幽默。”对我来说，那一刻，我身上那些我自知拥有却又最不想承认的特质，以及我最渴望拥有并希望自己确实具备的特质，以一种非常平淡的方式得到了认可。那种被一个成年人注视的感觉，不是用“这很好，这很坏，这可以接受”或这
isn't. But this is just what you are. This is what you're bringing to the table. It was scary in the best way because among many other things it was a moment of being told, maybe for the first time that you are showing up as you are, you're not pretending to be who you think you need to be in this moment. You were just bringing what you have to the table and you're offering something with it. Although Sarah didn't go on to become an actor, that moment helped her feel more confident in exploring her creative side. She is now an author and co-host of two podcasts.
不是这样的评判标准。而是：这就是你。这就是你带给舞台的东西。这是一种极好的、令人心悸的感觉，因为在诸多其他事情中，那一刻你被告知，或许是有生以来第一次：你展现的是真实的自己，你没有假装去成为你认为此刻自己需要成为的人。你只是把你拥有的东西带到桌面上，并以此提供一些东西。虽然莎拉后来没有成为一名演员，但那个时刻帮助她在探索自己富有创造力的一面时感到更加自信。她现在是一位作家，也是两个播客节目的联合主持人。
They call you're wrong about and you are good. If you would like to help us build more episodes like this, please act now. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org and join the hundreds of other hidden brain listeners who have signed up to help. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它们是《You're Wrong About》和《You Are Good》。如果你想帮助我们制作更多这样的节目，请现在就行动。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org，加入其他数百位已经注册提供帮助的 Hidden Brain 听众的行列。再次重申，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是香卡·韦丹坦。我们回头见。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。